a Chinese conference on artificial
intelligence is like a glimpse into the
future
[Music]
in an industry set to change the world
a lot of things here are fun and for the
crowds
but there is also serious Innovation for
India industry too
and products that will truly change
lives like this Rehabilitation Aid that
can read the body and feedback to
doctors I can't tell if I'm moving it or
it's moving me but it's a very strange
feeling
the world is watching What's Happening
Here is China winning the race to
develop and how well its capabilities be
used Baidu is China's equivalent of
Google and it's created China's best
consumer-facing chatbot and just listen
there's a pride and patriotic purpose to
this work
we believe that AI is bound to provide a
lot of support for the development of
industrial intelligence when Baidu and
Chinese Enterprises develop AI
technology we follow our president's
command setting our sights on health and
safety of the people and major
scientific needs of the country
and China is making exceptional strides
in some areas particularly in Military
and cyber security Fields it's why
America recently imposed strict new
regulations blocking China's access to
the most advanced chips and Technology
the so-called chips Act is China's key
challenge in this field and it could be
extended further as that competitive
relationship with America deepens most
experts agree that China is still a
little behind the us but it does have
other strengths and advantages and some
are more traditional and to understand
that we've come here to a tiny town over
a thousand miles from Shanghai in the
rural province of guijo
this place has become known as data
labeling town a place where workers
manually describe images to teach the AI
what it's looking at
it's vital and an area China is winning
because it has an abundance of
affordable labor
so yongjang and his friend have just
arrived here their students they tell us
and will do data labeling on the side
I feel I'm benefiting from AI he says
it's good to earn money and make a
living he adds
but if people power is a strength then
regulation could be a drawback an
experts say China will likely go further
than others the heavy-handed regulation
will hold the industry back the sense of
uncertainty it's very unclear I think
for tech companies what's allowed and
what's not and so they're going to be
very very hesitant I think in ways that
they might not have been saying like
2015.
this industry is developing so fast it's
hard to predict what will come next but
China is a serious player and it is
catching up Helena Smith Sky News in
Shanghai